hi
look at you you look like a little
valentine poem love it i just i needed a
little burst of optimism today we got it
but i i feel your outfit do you feel my
shoes i feel that's why i was looking at
your boots when i said that i know
because i said they said what do you
want to wear on drew and i said
my boots
because i'm comfortable and they protect
my ankle
which i was there right i mean literally
one minute okay so marishka and i are
hanging out we're going to see a
screening of black widow with friends
and
all of a sudden i'm in mariska's living
room at her house which is and i'm not
and she's not
because why it was so crazy so i i it's
such a i was just looking at a photos of
that we were having this screening and
then i left the screening early because
the party was going to be at my house so
excited so i left and i walk across the
street in the rain a little too fast
and down i go
on the street and fall down in the
middle of the street come out it hurts
so much it's this big long story short
in the ambulance i go
off to
the hospital and everyone's like what do
we do what do i do i said just tell
people i'm running an errand
and because i don't want to ruin the
party and it wasn't ruined apparently no
it really wasn't in fact i went through
your whole house not in a creepy way a
little creepy but go ahead but a little
creepy because i'm such a homemaker and
i have to say
your home is probably one of my favorite
homes i've ever been in in my whole life
oh it is the most magical charming nooks
vibes areas decor cozy i've also seen
things in your house i've never seen
anywhere else but can i just turn this
around and say to you that in i don't
know 25 years of doing this and talk
shows i just walked into the dressing
room drew and i didn't know what to do i
said stop the dressing rooms here are so
beautiful they're so special and i but
each one they're so beautiful though and
it made me feel like a like a fairy
princess all pinks and refrigerators
pink and the wallpaper and then like a
yellow and white couch and then each one
is different but it made me just go
and i felt that like home cozy
sort of like your outfit feeling i'm so
glad that's why it's a game changer
because i care about each little let's
run together oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
you